hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 116
retro 20th century cold war edition q
and a segment
all right
all right our question we'll just get
right in we're just going to not launch
that's a no we want to we want to not
say things like that the way we used to
not talk about anymore explosives and
airports and things like that yeah yeah
yeah
um
from the discord this week all right so
those of you who are on either of our
patreons get access to the discord and
every week they ask us a question
and here it is
i have been learning about the
phenomenon of the wef's young global
leaders who have infiltrated cabinets in
the words of klaus schwab
tulsi gabbard and dan crenshaw are among
them did you know this brett
yes i learned that this week this week
um
i will say i am on high alert about the
world economic forum and its
infiltration
of cabinets that said
i
know and quite like tulsi gabbard and
dan crenshaw
and i think we need to be very careful
not to
engage in too much heuristic thinking
which is to say to the extent that
either tulsi or dan or anybody else has
been persuaded by the royal economic
forum to betray their species and
destroy planet earth in a fit of great
reset or whatever it is that those crazy
people are up to
then that's a problem but to the extent
that somebody may have been
designated a young global leader and
then presumably encountered the great
reset plan for unmaking of the west
um and said hey klaus go [ __ ] yourself
um my feeling is all right that's all
well and good so
anyway i have i've seen no reason to
think that either one of these two
people was compromised by their
encounter with the wef and
anyway
i certainly hope that i'm
correct in my estimation of them
awesome
first question from
thedarkersubmissions.com site this week
do you know anything about the incident
at the high security lab in manitoba
here in canada
two scientists were escorted and removed
they had sent viruses to wuhan in early
2019 without authorization
everyone was immediately shocked that
one virus was ebola i'm more interested
in the other virus henipa
is it possible that it was this virus
that became coveted question mark i
can't make sense of trudeau's behavior
the unnecessary election the insistence
on 100 backs rate the most recent
debacle
um no i'm not aware of this
incident at all yeah i don't i don't
know and i and so i don't know
um
i don't know when i don't so
that's loud yes
um um i don't so you know it says they
had sent viruses to wuhan early 2019 but
i don't know if this incident is the
beginning of
kovid or now or or what yes well let's
decide
short version is we don't know about
this
we don't know about it um we are
stuck in the following predicament as
presumably
are most of our viewers and listeners
that
there does seem to be
an awful lot of nonsense about which
our
antagonists like trudeau
presumably have better information than
we do
i don't think we yet know what this is
about and
that's a problem because to the extent
that what we are trying to do is make
sense of the evidence as we are able to
to engage it
we effectively
have to
lag
behind what may be going on in other
words we don't want to get ahead of the
evidence in fact we should be somewhat
behind
the evidence
in terms of um concluding things but i
think we would be foolish
not to imagine that the rent-seeking
elites who have all sorts of unearned
power over us
have not found an angle in all of this
that benefits them at our expense right
um so anyway i uh quite independent
whether or not they were in any way
instrumental in making it all happen but
they you know they definitely have an
angle which they profit well let's put
it this way um
in the extreme
somebody could have caused
the coveted pandemic with purposes
short of that
there's all kinds of ways in which they
could have gotten the jump on the rest
of us
by having better information than we did
and my guess is the reality is somewhere
in there but i
i think all possibilities are
remain on the table except for we were
all caught equally off guard by this
which i think that
is not what happened
yeah we were not all equally caught off
guard
right and as for trudeau's behavior
it
it depends on what kind of a
what kind of a figure he is
and i mean he may not know what kind of
figure he is but you know he may be a
fall guy yeah i don't think uh
his
his um
i don't think it rises to the level of
behavior
that puts too kind of spin on what that
young man has been up to
he's like within a year or two of us
hence i think am i calling him a young
man maybe i'm wrong about that hopeful i
see kind of um
an assertion but anyway yes uh
he is
let's put it this way
behavior that's too generous misbehavior
begins to describe what he has been up
to maybe
yeah but that doesn't that's not that's
clarifying
was i trying to be clarified i thought
so
okay um and now for something completely
different
that's not what it says here it doesn't
say that it does not it does yeah yeah
and now for something completely
different the 20th century is back yeah
um
we could use those guys right by
does microbiome or diet account for more
variation of
the way that animal feces smells to
humans
for instance why does dog poop smell so
bad yet horse manure is tolerable and
here's a taboo
what brain steps allow one's own poop to
smell almost pleasant
well all right um there's two it's i
mean
thematically but i think it's two real
different questions no i uh so um
there's so many connections here but i
actually had a um
one of the guys who taught me uh bat
science uh charles handley one of the
great bat scientists of the 20th century
uh now gone but anyway he was the
smithsonian curator of mammals gone to
the great cave in the sky
yeah i'm i hope he i hope he has anyway
he was a very fascinating guy
fascinating guy who um
was as a young man
extremely intrepid right i think in fact
he had
cut his teeth as a biologist
on cross-country skis somewhere in the
arctic i don't know it was crazy he had
some
so the cut his teeth part of that was
metaphor
yeah okay um but then he went on to be a
tropical bat biologist um anyway having
a scene just enough of the arctic
fixture in the arctic team yes come up
with a better plan anyway he was a
interesting interesting guy at the point
i met him he was already
quite old but
um but anyway he studied bats um as
biologists are want to do yup he was
very focused on
archbious germaine census uh i believe
probably the most common fruit bat in uh
the neotropics at least in central
america
um
and then when he got too old to really
chase down the bats
he moved to
uh studying the fig trees that they were
so dependent on um anyway so that he
could still just you know the trees move
slower so they sure do um anyway he and
i as he was teaching me about bats we
were taking long
uh walks through the forest in panama
and bci and we had a conversation about
exactly this topic where i confronted
him
over the issue that there was an
evolutionary pattern to how things smell
to us and the problem is that most
people including charles at that point
didn't really have the sense of the way
evolution worked so they thought too
much
that this is basically some
um property of the poop in question yeah
rather than a property of the creature
the nose of the beholder as it were
um
and the point is this is the origin of
you talking about perception mediated
selection
right it was very much in that
neighborhood so anyway my point to
charles and my point to you in answer to
your question
is
that you have
a map
inside you and that map is about
hazard
right and the basic point is you can
predict how
terrible something will smell
based on
a historical and evolutionary historical
guess as to how likely that thing is to
be dangerous to you which then has all
kinds of interesting implications so um
yeah uh
horse poop doesn't smell that bad horse
is pretty distantly related to you as a
mammal
and therefore the chances that something
in its feces and we also have a pretty
uh decent history in uh
with horses so the point is the hazard
to you that is posed by the poop of the
horse is likely to be low relative to
the poop of other apes
the
poop of members of your own species
which is likely to be particularly
hazardous yeah but i don't think you can
do it um
mostly by phylogeny uh because ungulates
um that we have domesticated so i i
could see an argument being made for you
know dog poop smells particularly bad
because there are domesticates we're
eating the same stuff we share a lot of
our microbiome they are likely therefore
to be able to share pathogens with us
same thing potentially for cats but um
but
a
fresh carnivore poop of non-domesticated
species also smells bad now as soon as
it it
it gets
it stops smelling so bad pretty quickly
but um
i would have excuse me
i would have thought it might be about
the degree of domestication
uh and i'm not immediately able to
recall exactly what the mammal tree
looks like but uh horses and carnivorous
are both basically pretty distantly
related to primates so it can't it can't
be a phylogenetic closeness you're
you're taking part of my argument but
not the whole argument okay my point is
it's about hazard yes hazard is going to
have components one of which will be
phylogenetic another of which is going
to be ecological and i'm not totally
convinced by what you say about wild
carnivore poop
um
i guess i haven't
it's a little hard to say because
typically when you happen onto it it's
not all that fresh and so it may be that
my sense that it isn't all that noxious
is the result of uh a temporal issue i
so i i i think that's right although i'm
not 100 sure and i think basically we
are much more likely to have run into
uh the poop of our own species and our
domesticates well which is
which obviously doesn't um allow us to
assess uh the other part of the question
i just i don't think that phylogeny is
going to play much of a role at all here
i think it's going to be about diet and
and and gut
plus domestication uh no
well let's put it this way phylogeny
will play a role especially
as you get very close to your own
species at least within your own species
you're liable to have special markers
especially because
we are a social species and so therefore
to the extent
that one person sickens another person
in their group that's bad for the
lineage and so
and actually this goes back to a
discussion in uh randy nessie's um
course on uh evolution of medicine and
evolution of medicine but um but anyway
the point is the sociality of our
species is liable to make
feces from our own
uh
kin particularly noxious our kin meaning
just members of our species in this case
this does go to the grotesque but
uh
apt portion of your question about
why the smell of one's own feces is
exceptional and the answer is because
it's not likely to make you sick
right
um and in fact you can imagine i don't
know this is a hypothesis here but i'm
not sure i'd buy this what do you mean
how could you not
well a i'm not sure i buy the premise of
the question
um
and
uh i guess it might be more less likely
to make you sick than
the [ __ ] of someone else but it still
has the capacity to make you sick well
not really not i mean maybe maybe but
not really you know if it's sat
somewhere so that bacteria from
elsewhere has colonized it yeah and yes
it very definitely would but but
you're going to be hard to infect
yourself with something that you're
already infected with
and so
you could also imagine imagine that your
own [ __ ] smelled as horrifying as
everyone else's right what does that do
to the developmental training of a young
person having to learn how to control
that bodily function if they get
penalized every time they poop somewhere
right so you could imagine
i guess like again i just i don't i
don't i i've never heard this before i
don't i don't agree with the premise it
does smell just as bad no no of course
it smells just as bad but the question
is do you
find it exceptional and i think what you
are responding to is that an
adult with a proper developmental
environment learns to encode it like
everyone else's and in fact we you know
there's this
famous saying about you know that person
thinks her [ __ ] doesn't stink right
um and the point is that's a reference
to the fact that it's encoded the
mapping is different and that a person
might infer that that actually implies
something about their special quality
rather than implies something about
their
relationship to the contents of their
own gut well aside from the particulars
here there is a question of absolute
versus relative which is what the uh
what your overall answer is about right
that it's not that
um
horse [ __ ] does not smell bad
it's that for humans given what it is
that we can get sickened by and
therefore what we need to be made aware
of horseshit doesn't smell bad right and
so you know smell bad is a relative is a
claim
of perception as opposed to a absolute
quality exterior to the nose of the
person smelling it of the thing that you
are smelling right now i will point out
that there are certain things that fit
this pattern very well right like the
horrifying smell of
fish or
shellfish that have been sitting in the
sun
right particular hazard the things that
grow on these things are very dangerous
right and so what you should probably
imagine in order to see how all this
works yep
is a starving ancestor
who encounters various things that might
be consumed and
the smell
index is going to be something of a
guide of how reluctant you should be
about various things and note
that
sushi
tastes good
right really fresh fish right that has
not been cooked is actually safe and
uh as such does not smell horrifying
right
fish that has been sitting out takes on
an odor very rapidly that would
absolutely dissuade you from
experimenting unless you were in just
the
uh deepest kind of starvation yeah and i
would also point out that cadavers
have a special smell and this is again
going to be a matter of
within species it makes sense to connote
a particular warning
and the warning i believe is likely to
be about dissuading
people from consuming members of their
own species right and the point is it's
not that the individual number of your
species is likely to convey some
pathogen to you if you were to consume
their flesh or their organs
but the danger of opening up that
pathway is so great
right that the hazard to your lineage
going forward if it were to get the idea
that eating corpses was a good idea
right that hazard then evolution would
find that path and having found that
path the cost to your descendants would
be immense and so i believe that
selection has built in a penalty to make
that experiment very very unlikely
awesome all right we need to get to a
really less gross topic all right let's
do it
um
example i haven't i haven't read this
yet so bear with me example of mirror
universe gaslighting
would it have occurred to trudeau to
accuse the truckers of one stealing from
the homeless two soiling streets and
three waving nazi flags
if
the feeding of the homeless the cleaning
of the streets and the waving of
canadian flags had not been the three
most dominant spectacles
wow that's really interesting yeah um
i mean it's also
it's it sort of follows the principle of
you accuse someone of something they
absolutely aren't guilty of and their
denial of it makes some portion of the
people hearing the denial think that
they're guilty because the act of saying
no i didn't
triggers some part of us i'm sure
there's some psychological principle
here but um being forced to say what are
you talking about i didn't do that
unless you can do that really kind of in
exactly that way like are you kidding me
no um but you know politicians being
forced to say of course i didn't why i
would i wouldn't do that they always end
up looking guilty and so even if it's
totally made-up thing so in this case
yeah saying the exact opposite of what
is true
also can be extraordinarily flustering
right just like are you are you kidding
me we're doing the opposite but the
claim like we're doing the opposite also
makes
makes you look not entirely trustworthy
because what are the chances that he's
lying that big well he is
yeah it's a fascinating puzzle i mean
we've all encountered
truly terrible people who make a habit
of accusing you or someone else of
exactly the thing that they are guilty
of right and it is they're doing it as
they're doing it and it is it is
bewildering yeah right it is
the hardest thing to field it's like
right
um
and so yeah mirror universe gaslighting
yes mirror universe gaslighting so
there are
there are various
functions where you get
two payoffs in one move and i wonder if
this isn't one of these things where if
if you're a truly terrible person like
let's say trudeau for example
right
just for instance for example truly
terrible um um if you were a truly
terrible trudeau style person or
something on camera at some point no it
doesn't make them a good person some
yeah
the whole blackface thing just imagine
what you're going well yes
um
truly terrible trudeau style person
right at the point that they accuse you
of exactly the thing that they are doing
they have gotten two benefits one they
have delivered a completely vile
accusation right because they being vile
and engaged in the thing have now
delivered that stigma to you because
they are terrible and have no conscience
and
they have also then complexified your
life because to the extent that your
instinct is to say
no that's what you do the point is well
as he said she said or whatever right
well the truth must be exactly in the
middle no it must not all i know is that
trudeau and those other people are
accusing each other of the thing and i
don't can tell but i know that i wish i
could drive through the streets more
easily so right i guess i'll go with you
yeah so it's i think it's
the double benefit yeah of if you well
he does this with his freaking pandering
to uh to to wokism as well you know like
literally blackface dude who's somehow
getting away with with flying the black
lives matter flag is it as if as if all
that didn't happen yeah
right right right no the guy with the
race problem is
accusing the truckers with
you know yes the mandate problem of
having some race problems yes and a
problem of the race problem guys making
yeah yes okay
well there we are that was
fun
um
myocarditis
the fact that only some people suffer
post-facts is it due to random
distribution of
spike protein
bad luck
or
might some people be more susceptible to
genetic due to genetics or some tolerate
it better and never notice the weaker
course of illness ah sweet yeah we can
do this yeah so yeah
it's written sort of telegraphically so
i was just trying to translate it as i
was reading it
many things are true one there is liable
to be a roll of the dice thing right
like you've got an actual
volume of liquid with actual stuff in it
and it's going to circulate in some
chaotic way and to the extent that
particular
uh lipid nanoparticle coated pieces of
rna
bump into the walls and the heart and
then get absorbed whereas others were
you know three millimeters away from the
heart as they went through
tissues downstream
all of that
chaotic flow stuff is going to mean that
some people are going to get a huge dose
in the heart some people are going to
get a very low dose in the heart and the
aspiration thing that john campbell
surfaced may have everything to say
about this because the point is maybe
everybody who gets a huge dose in the
heart are people where the
needle actually hit a circulatory vessel
rather than the interstitial
space
there might be something about the
variation between batches although i
don't know if we know anything about
what the variation between batches
vaccine batches
uh actually means in terms of how it
manifests in the body yeah if it's even
a thing and right it's tough to to face
down
um there could be here heritable
differences my guess is it's very small
yeah me too if it's a component at all
um i think i mean because because it's
your heart right it could be because
because you simply
there's simply no backup
and uh if it gets there it's going to be
a problem for you i was thinking
actually when we were talking in the
first hour
um you know what else
obviously you you and debbie spent a
long time thinking about this for you
know many years but you know what else
might be like the heart and therefore
you would predict to have really low
repair capacity and the one thing i came
up with and it's not perfect because we
got two of them
is the loop of henle in the kidney not
kidney tissue writ large but
specifically the mammalian synapomorphy
the the the unique character of
mammalian kidneys that allows for um
uh basically the recovery of more water
and the excretion of of liquid waste
through that thing that's called the
loop of henle which is so thin that you
know a problem there could could
similarly take one of your kidneys
offline
yeah potentially right away you've got
so many actual loops of henle right i
mean these are
tiny structures and you have presumably
millions of them
no
it's a
i'm trying i hope i'm not wrong here but
you know there's lots of little things
off of it but like in the main loop
uh
i'm gonna stay out of it because i don't
know okay um
yeah i think you got two basically well
um but but maybe i'm wrong about that
let's see you've got other tissues that
behave in a weird way
um and i would argue
what i argued in the paper back in
the late 90s early 2000s was
um
that certain tissues have reasons not to
have high repair capacity and that all
of them are low
cancer risk
and high
uh
wearing out potential
basically that's the pattern that any
tissue in which you've got
high repair capacity has a substantial
risk of tumor growth and a substantial
capacity to repair damage but that
things like the eye
the eye has a low capacity for repair
and tends to wear out
cartilage has very little capacity for
repair um and tends to wear out and you
don't get
cartilage cancer
and you don't get eye cancer but you get
like optic nerve cancer there's nervous
tissue
blood vessel cancer
but the eye itself doesn't tend to get
cancer right right yeah right and the
heart doesn't tend to get cancer right
pericardium the membrane around the
heart does when people get cancers right
uh in that neighborhood that tends to be
the pericardium but anyway it's a
general general that's interesting
because of course myocarditis and
pericarditis are the two or the two
kinds of inflammation that are really
happening here and and all of the
discussion that we had earlier was about
myocarditis not pericarditis which is an
inflammation of the pericardium which is
the membrane around the heart well
actually this might form some
pericardial cavity i forgot to say in
our main podcast which is that
effectively the hypothesis
uh that i put forward
is a hypothesis of
temporary
autoimmunity
right the idea of that
so we've got
autoimmunity is the immune system
mistaking self
for hostile and attacking self
my argument is
the mrna in heart tissue
is likely to trigger the immune system
to attack the heart but the
mrna transcripts that cause the
production of the spike protein are
presumably transient
and so the point is if the if the immune
system were to hold back and not attack
these cells the cells would go back to
being normal
and so the point is it is a temporary
autoimmunity that causes the permanent
destruction of cells in the heart
that then results in the heart being
effectively enfeebled damaged um
so anyway i wish i had said that in the
main podcast but
here's what it is that's what it is
indeed um
and then the i mean there's
more categories than this but these this
does seem like a good group of three is
it luck
is it genetics is it terrible um or do
some tolerate it better and never notice
the weaker course of illness ah so this
is a biggie yeah
um if the hypothesis is correct one of
the things that it predicts is that
there will be a ton of subclinical
myocarditis that will never be described
and what that means the way we will see
it manifest is shortened life spans
right a large fraction of people
ultimately die from heart failure and
that those deaths will happen earlier
than they would otherwise have happened
because their heart has effectively
expended what compare repair capacity it
has early in life
and been
caused to be less capable
now this of course fits
with
the
observation which i believe is likely to
be robust that we have an unusual number
of people dying
during uh sporting events and the basic
point is that athletes are being pushed
to a limit that most people are not
regularly pushed to and that the point
is a heart that can function below that
threshold will suddenly fail when
stressed to a point because it has lost
some of its heart capacity
to vaccines that trigger this temporary
autoimmunity yeah and there's something
new out which i haven't tracked yet
about catecholamines and you know sort
of having an environment in which
adrenaline and noradrenaline and
dopamine i think is the third
catecholamine
um being at elevated levels may make
uh heart failure and the already
compromised heart more likely the
myocarditis in an already compromised
heart more likely um but i can't but i
can't track it more than that yet yeah i
have
it's on my list of places to delve but i
haven't i haven't delved into that
result yet
is it possible that we could be
genetically selecting unintentionally
for partners with a work drive to help
provide for a family now that most
households require more than one
breadwinner
um
yeah but i mean i don't think we need
the word genetically in there
yeah we don't need genetically it's
unlikely to be genetic because the time
it would take for such a thing i mean a
you've got to evolve some genetic
mechanism for recognizing such a thing
and it's a lot easier to
a culture these things are well
understood i mean we know that they
exist culturally things like the
protestant work ethic right
and um you also don't really need the
end of that question right because
is always
productive so the nature of the work
that we're selecting
for
in partners may be changing
right that you know desiring to you know
bring in money to the household as
opposed to doing a division of labor uh
in which um some of the work is
definitely not bread winning per se
um is
it's less possible yeah in modernity
right and so to the extent that there's
a potential pattern here a i believe
women will traditionally have always
favored this characteristic
and to the extent that there is a impact
of needing two breadwinners to float a
family
what you will see is that men will
prioritize will begin to prioritize
since some this is from echo we haven't
heard from echo in a while
echo
since some races are supposed to be more
racist would making the elites more
phenotypically diverse create conditions
for more humane globalist policies to
emerge downstream
love you too
well
boy i'm trying to try to understand that
question certainly having more diverse
elites
or phoenix typically diverse elites
um
you know if
we're the elite class
is a is a problem
but
actually a more phenotypically diverse
elite class
would allay some of the problem
that they create but would it be
substantial enough to
make a difference as opposed to just
going after the elite class yeah i don't
think so because i think the you know
this is one of these very frustrating
phenomena is
the truly terrible elites
don't have time for racism they just
don't right they have time to get the
rest of us bent out of shape over it but
the basic point is you'd be a sucky
rent-seeking elite if you allowed
somebody's color to dissuade you from
making a completely despicable bargain
with them
to
make money and accumulate power so the
basic point is well but you might want
your country to to win
yes except that's the thing about rent
seeking elites that's why they suck so
badly as they've abandoned that our dog
is gonna eat the fedex guy i think
that's unlikely okay um
but anyway the point is this the problem
if you if your elites are nationalists
right and mind you nationalist is the
version of this i like least i like the
patriot i don't like the nationalists
and i see them as distinct
but if your elites are nationalists then
they are in effect
using your
nation as a weapon to advance the
interests of your lineage
right
but the problem with the rent-seeking
elites is that's so cumbersome right
being obligated to a nation is just
going to block opportunity after
opportunity so what they do is they
abandon things like nation and lineage
and they become
extreme
greedy and opportunistic and
opportunistic is inconsistent
with being prejudiced
right and this is in some sense why we
see these like
crazy pictures of
george w bush holding hands with a sheik
right it's like you would not expect
some swaggering texas dude
to be holding hands with a sheik you
would expect that to be well outside
of the
um
the overton window for a provincial blah
blah blah but what you're not getting is
that he's essential
he's not provincial he's a he you know i
don't mean to be he's never provincial
particularly i don't think he's the
worst of them but
as it turns out no but um but they're
you know
he he came to power in part by
and i don't know that was his choice but
you know by having his
provincial seeming ways played up you
know he's a country guy who likes to
clear tumbleweeds or something it's for
the cameras yeah it's for the cameras
and the point is that's that's the thing
i think people don't anticipate is that
because
the elites are not playing for the team
that they
would like you to believe they're
playing for it's part of why people get
suckered by them if they think that the
elites are cheating on their behalf and
the fact is the elites are cheating on
their own behalf and they're
using you and they are using racism in
the population but they don't have time
for it because it blocks
honest-to-goodness opportunities to rape
and pillage their way through history
which is their
you know that's their bread and butter
yep
okay
in an effort to prevent what happened to
ukraine from happening further east i'm
wondering if it wouldn't be a bad idea
for a bunch of well-trained american
soldiers to voluntarily take an extended
vacation to taiwan
[Music]
well
yeah the problem is it is not obvious
that in our
stupefyingly stupid state that we are
actually in a position
to defend
taiwan
this is really the question is have we
left ourselves
in a position where
we can't even
back up the world that we
depend on continuing to exist
yeah and you know i i think
it's so frustrating to watch
the blue team cynically obsess about the
russians while
engaging in the most studied ignorance
of the hazard of the chinese when in
fact the point is
okay you've now got a multi-polar world
yeah and multiple hazards and you had a
beautiful equilibrium which you forgot
to notice and forgot
to realize your continued capacity to do
what you do was dependent on that
equilibrium
you stopped noticing it the same way you
stop noticing
that it is miraculous that there is
always food in the supermarket yeah and
the point is if you're like
upending the process that puts food in
your supermarket because you've become
so used to there always being food that
you've forgotten that you're dependent
on this process you know nothing about
then you could upend it and then one day
it'll be like well wait a minute i'm
entitled to have food in my supermarket
and it won't be there yep
i'm gonna cough i'm gonna read you a
question i'm gonna go and cough
somewhere else all right um what's the
most proactive action one can take
regarding the state of the world
what is the most proactive action yeah i
think i think i've got this
what you want to do
is find
people
that you can actually
depend on
and this is not
sufficient to protect you but it does
greatly increase
your
uh
your robustness and maybe more
importantly your anti-fragility
in the face of an uncertain world that
is to say
let's suppose you have miscalculated and
you've misunderstood what the hazard in
the world is and something goes wrong
but you have
found other people who are
good at thinking who are
confronting the same puzzle well they're
liable to fill in what's in your blind
spot so that you stop being blind to it
um and to the extent that somebody has
figured out what the right
way to endure
a rough patch is
um
you know you can team up you can you can
engage in collective defense of the
essentials somehow
that sounded like a good answer when i
heard of it i think so yeah yeah it's
not sufficient
well i can't expect sufficiency with a
big answer i have a big question
i understand loudly theory is very
strong but have you seen professor
edward steele's work suggesting cyrus
kobe 2 came from meteorite shower any
thoughts
this is brand new to me yeah no i
haven't and no i can't really imagine
that could possibly be the case
i mean it can't
it can't be from outside of
the earth because because it's of this
earth it's got the informational
molecule of
planet earth
yeah no other other other planets don't
have chronoviruses because we're number
one
we are number one yeah biologically but
not for long
no i think we're pretty much number one
biologically for the first number one in
coronaviruses certainly and drops
yes
uh can i have myocarditis without
symptoms will it go away
i got tinnitus three days after the
booster since i have no recourse should
i cheat on my taxes since the government
cheated me
wow yeah you should you shouldn't not
cheat on your taxes you shouldn't but uh
they really are not holding up there
into the bargain are they nope they are
not they are not uh can you have
myocarditis without symptoms yeah i mean
i think this is the subclinical um stuff
that you're referring to and uh for sure
there will be people who have damage and
who
are never aware that they have damage
and may never become aware they have
damage or may become aware later oh it
looks like you have some past damage
your doctor tells you 20 years later and
you say no i really don't ah well
could have been that injection yep
uh anything else to say here will it go
away um it does it seems to pass but um
but it doesn't it's it leaves scarring
well it will reduce the capacity of your
heart presumably for life now there no i
i want to take that back yeah i don't
know that's true no i believe it's true
okay but let's put it to you this way i
think what i've learned from peter
mccullough
is
that you really have two kinds of
myocarditis you've got an inflammation
that goes away but
is not the result of cellular
destruction that the myocarditis that is
the result of cellular destruction will
permanently reduce the capacity of your
heart which depending upon what you do
you know if you're an elite athlete
probably won't be an elite athlete after
that happens
and mccullough's argument is the kind of
myocarditis that does not involve
cellular destruction is the kind that
sars kobe 2 causes
but that the kind of myocarditis
that does cause cellular destruction is
brought on by presumably among other
things uh the mrna vaccines is that is
that the right categorization i think so
i don't want to represent his position
because if i've got it wrong i've got it
wrong
but yes i believe that is his argument
okay
could there be an epigenetic mechanism
that would tell the offspring how
ravenous to be based on whether the
parent experienced just
the final word is starvation let me read
it again could there be an epigenetic
mechanism that would tell the offspring
how ravenous to be based on whether the
parent experienced starvation yeah and
um i'm i am not immediately familiar
with the literature but there is
there is some of exactly this suggesting
i mean i think this is like the
epigenetic thing that was one of the
first to be discovered in like rats and
skipping generations yes and and uh i've
forgotten which population it is some
very far in population humans
in which
as i recall it bodies
were buried and effectively frozen which
allowed
for some
[Music]
testing 100 years later or something
like that i i've forgotten the story but
yes this exact pattern has been seen
that
famine
uh triggers an alteration in hunger in
later generations hunger and i think um
even like what is it like ghrelin um
metabolism like actually
um take like not just not just
acquisition of calories but then holding
on to those calories like fat deposition
yeah yeah absolutely um absolutely
such that those who have experienced
famine um in their in their recent
lineage are more likely
um to you know
not starve um but also not have as easy
a time keeping to the weight they may
want to be at if they live in a time of
plenty yep
yep
do you have thoughts
on working in the industrial food
industry
i work in a food microbiology lab
testing processed foods i feel like i'm
contributing to the poor health of the
country
um well
uh certainly we have a problem with
food novelty
and this is one of these places where
the
sales
orientation of everything results in us
focusing on
the glorious aspects of all of these
novel foods and ignoring the horrifying
risk to our health
yeah
what what and
there's put in the book there's one
like now well-known example the
anti-fungals
in the shelf stable foods
um
are associated are now associated
understood to be associated with some
number of uh neurological disorders i
believe i can't remember exactly the
specifics um
that all said um you know testing
processed foods
like
yeah contributing to this part of the
economy is
you know
given that you asked the question
probably not
uh if you
had complete freedom to choose what you
would be choosing to do with your
talents
um
but what are you testing these processed
foods for
you know given that this is the economy
that we live in now and that many people
are depending on these things are you
testing are you effectively doing food
uh safety testing uh for food that no is
not particularly good for us and is
making a lot of people very sick and is
you know the fact that more americans
eat this kind of food and therefore more
americans are obese um directly ties to
the fact that more americans got really
really sick from covin than people in
ethiopia did
you know that that is true on the other
hand you also don't want people getting
sick from the actual um you know from
pathogens in the food either yeah it i
mean it's a it's a precautionary issue
the point is you've got the diet that
your body is expecting and any deviation
from what runs the risk of
making things worse
yeah
um
do i need to find a question that you
can disappear for okay
uh here's two of them you can just hear
them they're sort of related was the
extinction of the dinosaurs a one-time
event and spring spring northern or
southern hemisphere so these are both
about about that
um so run off all right run off then
um
let's see i've now lost the question it
was about um dinosaurs yes the dinosaurs
we think
um
the evidence suggests that exactly
exactly right it was it was a singular
event um but as i mentioned in the first
hour um the predominant hypothesis which
is chicksaleb this meteor that hit off
the northern coast of the yucatan
um
caused
um you know huge disruption not just not
just anything localized but it was a it
was a giant giant meteor and and it
caused the extinctions worldwide
there is also a possibility of a
i think maybe there's a comet that's now
being talked about um that presumably
would have hit somewhere else
um and then there's also these uh the
the
deccan traps in in india which is um
which caused a lot of climate change
that wasn't just just local um
so regardless though they were
uh
one of those events or
two probably not three but two
um two of them acting in concert were
responsible for yes the extinction of
the non-avian dinosaurs um so i mean i
guess it's not a one-time event because
the dinosaurs are still with us the
avian dinosaurs still being with us all
the ones that matter
all the ones that we can currently point
to not even that no uh so spring
northern southern hemisphere yeah this
is this is actually part of what um we
didn't get to in the first hour um
northern spring
uh the evidence is from some fish
at a site i think it's tavis site maybe
in
was it south dakota maybe north dakota
south dakota um
wherein you can tell from the way and i
can't remember i'm not looking at my
notes right now
you could tell by the way some of the
bone is being laid down what part of
their seasonal cycle they're in and so
it was the northern hemisphere spring
when all these fish and like everyone
else suddenly disappeared
and the idea is that
it was organisms
mammalian organisms in the south
that lived far enough south that they
would have had to deal with the winter
and therefore might have been already
underground hibernating burrowing or
something would have been protected for
the first several months after the
impact if it was jigsaw
and thus had a greater chance of
surviving and of course that would have
been the the gondwanan distribution the
the the organisms in the you know what
is modern day australia south america
india madagascar australia
antarctica um
whereas the organisms in larasia in
modern day
north america
europe and most of asia
would have been more immediately
impacted because it was spring and
everyone was out and about
so
is the implication yeah that the mammals
and i guess it would likely be the birds
too that yeah um were all
southern hemisphere and that the
northern hemisphere was repopulated by
birds and mammals from yeah it can't be
exactly that because there's a lorasian
distribution like you know a lot of the
placentals yeah
we're we're asian distribution so i
actually not go back and look at the
maps that i've got of what we think
everything looked like at that point
landmass wise
which maybe i should do because um maybe
we just weren't a split up yet um
as it seems
um
and of course you know birds
birds have an ability to move across
landscapes more easily than than the
mammals do
but yeah i mean this this part of the
story
about what they're for
which
which geographic distribution of clay to
be been more likely to survive seems
weak yeah
but the idea that
we can
look into the bones well enough to see
what the growth patterns are and when
they stopped and therefore what season
it was
for those animals whose bones it was is
remarkable to me
yeah i must say um
it's uh probably too much inside
baseball but
we
end up
um with certain views of
biases inside other
biological disciplines
yeah your son's not paying attention no
um oh for a second it was a
ventriloquist but um
it's funny let's start again you and i
have certain you know there are certain
exasperating features of the cellular
molecular biologists right there's
certain kind of myopia about evolution
for example amongst the cellular
molecular biologists and a propensity to
name things in an atrocious way like to
take a gene that is responsible for eyes
and to name it eyeless because if you
disrupt the gene you lose your eyes
right and then there is a kind of myopia
and do gritterness among uh many
ecologists
all right so you sort of i mean we
definitely we don't always master the
naming although gorilla gorilla gorilla
is a good one oh man yeah you just did
really you know hammers the point home
but
um
but anyway
there are also disciplines that one does
not end up rolling their eyes at quite
so much and i must tell you you know as
you and i developed a healthy respect
for the philosophy of science
and its importance even though dick
alexander always was exasperated at
those folks
the paleo people yeah
have a lot right there's a lot it's it's
one of the harder disciplines to do well
because basically as bad as
the problem is of evolution
having
had much of the evidence erased by time
paleo is like the worst of the worst of
that um but there are these amazing
stories in which they are able to read
things like the seasonality of um yeah
incredible and i mean just
as far as i've seen you know really
definitely not being a paleontologist at
all
um the inferences that they make they
are not just able to but inclined to lay
them out for you yeah and be like this
is hey we think we think
f we think f because we saw a and then
from that we applied
technique over here and got b and that
must follow and if b then c
and hey we gotta do a little fancy thing
here so there's a little bit of a black
box here but then if we're right about
what d means then e and you know like
you could just follow the logic in a way
that's
this is what all scientists should be
doing all the time what we try to do but
what most people who are calling
themselves scientists now make just no
attempt at whatsoever they're like well
f
we were there
see scientist therefore f what did you
do what's your evidence what did you see
it is it is the it's the opposite of the
sales thing because in some sense it's
like everything interesting that the
paleo folks tell us is like well wait
how how could you possibly know that
right and maybe they know they know the
burden of proof it's like i know you're
not going to believe i can know this but
check it out but check it out and it's
like you know
conclusion x
really
how do you know that spring time and
it's like
hear me out right it's like every paleo
thing is like it no hear me out right
and the thing is it's amazing how often
they deliver the goods yeah and it's
like actually yeah that's that is pretty
compelling argument you know
yep yeah
cool
um
if most people orient through social
pressure and marketing
under democracy don't we need to focus
on this
are we imposing a meritocracy
wait try that again if most people
orient through social pressure and
marketing under democracy don't we need
to focus on this are we imposing a
meritocracy
i don't think i quite get it well
i i i got something in the neighborhood
okay
you there's a question like
in um
in physics very often we have a
instantaneous measure of something
and
a
integrative measure right and this is
one of the things actually
our measure of fitness
is polluted by
an overly close relationship with
reproduction
right we evolutionists have gotten lazy
because in general
if you leave more offspring on a short
time scale
it makes you more
unlikely to go extinct in a long time
scale for example
right and so
we get lazy and we start to think that
fitness is reproductive success and
there are lots of cases in which fitness
isn't reproductive success in fact they
go in the opposite direction
but we're less good at thinking about
them and so what i would argue
is
all right here's some place i've
changed my mind over my lifetime okay
when i was a kid my grandfather used to
argue
that um the key
to the world working
was education
and i knew for sure he was wrong
because you found him naive well the
game theory is what it is
and the fact that you may know that it's
a commons that will suffer a tragedy if
you over exploit it doesn't solve the
problem
and so in some sense education about a
tragedy of the commons does not prevent
a tragedy at the conference
on the other hand
the
problem that the person asking this
question is pointing to is in some sense
why are we such suckers
right and that's really the issue it's
not you know it's not that the market is
a problem
it's that suckers in the market are a
problem and if you're a sophisticated
consumer in a marketplace of ideas who
knows how to sort out attractive
sounding [ __ ] from
reality then the fact that there's
attractive sounding [ __ ] isn't such
a big problem and so
in any case
i think the point is
you need to have the educational
experience that allows you to know when
you're being lied to
right it allows you to detect it and if
that were the case then the lies
wouldn't be so damn devastating and yeah
fact that we're dealing with a bunch of
people who've gotten really good at
lying and never got really good at
spotting lies it's like oh that's the
worst of both worlds yeah it is
everybody's a liar and nobody spots lies
and yeah so the point is you're all like
lashing about as the rent seekers are
jerking your chain and telling you oh
here's the you know great danger this
week that you need our solution for or
you're going to die and it's well it's
consistent too
there seems to be rarely hear it stated
but there seems to be an assumption on
many people's part like well yeah
obviously everyone's lying well no
some of us really are not well so really
you're trying not to
then the idea that well that's just the
world we live in we all lie
no no some of us explicitly never signed
up for that and have no intention of
letting that world become the future if
we can stop it right and look what
happened to us during covet is you've
got
you know you've got
cynics who were like everybody's lying
right and then you've got the
died in the wool liars
and then you've got the dissidents and
the point is how you understand the
dissonance is entirely dependent on
whether or not you had any nuance in
this function at all
and if you did have nuance in this
function then you realize oh your
dissidents are mislabeled as heretics
right your dissidents have been labeled
as grifters and as
um spreaders of
mal information or whatever stupidity
they're deploying to make it so you'll
look somewhere else but the basic point
is actually no there were a bunch of
people telling you the truth and yeah
they're just mislabeled so that you
won't listen to them but
i'm reminded of the fact that my parents
uh originally wanted to name me
cassandra
and my father uh decided uh imagining
that the the people i would be running
into in my life were probably a bit more
educated in uh mythology than they
actually were he decided that was um
not a fair faint to give to a daughter
because he did not want to see
see his daughter
faded to tell the truth and never be
believed right yes no it's a it's a hell
of a burden for a girl but um
anyway
um i don't think it worked though the
changing of the name
okay no you got stuck with the job yeah
you got the job just with a different
name um speaking of following up on
something you just said
mauricio writes following your mdm
analysis that was the misinformation
disinformation mal information
analysis from two weeks ago what are
your thoughts on discords terms of
service now allowing users to snitch and
report misinformation resulting in
perma-bans
yeah
we are probably gonna need to find
another home yeah well
what do we think about it though yeah um
could you people who
think you know what the truth is enough
to diagnose when other people aren't
saying it could you get over your
[ __ ] selves because what discord
discord is a server designed for gamers
to talk to each other about
fanciful worlds that don't exist and if
you think
you are so good at figuring out what the
truth is that you can tell people who is
speaking intolerable falsehoods then
how did you come by that capacity is it
magic
because the rest of us are trying to
figure out what's true by talking stuff
through and if you can't do that on
discord then what's it for
right
i mean this is this is the question for
all of these platforms the point is how
do we figure out what's true we do so
by discussing it and there's actually
methods for figuring out you know i mean
in fact we talked about it in the first
hour of the podcast
right we figure out
what is true based on
which truths provide predictive power
and is there a division of predictive
power at discord
right do these people have a department
of predictive power that is going to
allow them to figure out what the truths
are that they are the stewards of yeah
because i don't think so and i think
frankly you know whatever
25 year old intern it is that came up
with the idea that they are in such a
privileged position regarding truth that
person needs to go back to school well
but uh you know
the hammer's coming down right i don't i
don't think this is this is being
generated by the 25 year old interns in
so far as we have empowered them to
imagine that they get gold stars for
everything and they are
living in a world in which uh truth
appears to be a matter of opinion and uh
everyone is lying all the time
but
uh the fact that all of the platforms
are circling the wagons even more than
they were last summer now
and deciding uh that science is not
science and uh reality is not reality
it suggests i mean i'm reminded of like
my very first substance piece fact
checkers aren't scientists you know like
the the the hubris
of the fact-checking arm of facebook for
instance which is a politifact i think
um
in which they
you know they gave i can't have to go
back and look at it but i think they
gave
some click they gave some claim that you
made
that was you know two months later
demonstrated to be likely to be correct
i think it was pants on fire rating
which is like their their highest level
of like can you believe this [ __ ]
right it's like that level pants on they
literally call it pants on fire and i
believe liar liar pants on fire
and
like who again some like 25 year old
intern presumably who has like a
sociology degree or you know worse
and on
on what basis like when did we forget
what scientists
do and how they think and how we're all
supposed to be doing science at least a
little bit all the time and oh by the
way your opinion today that someone is
lying doesn't make it
true
doesn't make it true and that kids is
the story of how we got politifucked
um yeah no it's it's it's crazy and and
the question is look
simple i mean i mean this is really the
the constantine point again civilization
functions on the basis of certain
agreements yeah one of those agreements
is that we get to talk about our doubts
about things and if we're wrong about
them
then we will find that out through
discussion not through somebody telling
us we're not allowed to say those bad
things we have to we have to it's the
only way we have to talk about them
right
otherwise we we do we live in a
huxley-esque orwellian landscape that no
one
should want to live in right and the
point is the people inside these
organizations however this happens
whether it's the federal government
issuing secret mandates behind the
scenes whether it is them hinting that
if you do this thing
uh we will leave you alone and if you
don't we will wreck your business
whatever it is that's happening the
people inside need to find their balls
and stand up to it right they do because
civilization depends on there being some
place that we can talk yep and if you
haven't figured this out two years into
this pandemic then you need to pay
attention to a wider
set of phenomena because the fact is the
people who are issuing these mandates
have yet to be right about anything
important
yep
competing hypothesis
blood goes to the heart twice before
going on to liver kidneys gonads signs
of ovarian damage exist nobody's
studying it well
uh i like it and i there is something to
the idea of blood goes to the heart
twice but it goes on two different sides
and so we ought to be able
to sort we ought to be able to look at
the damage and actually read this
pattern into it
yeah i don't i don't
i don't buy this precisely because we
have a four chambered heart and um
there's a little
um a bit of slosh but for the most part
um the four chambered heart keeps the
pulmonary and the systemic circuitry
completely separate
and so the you know the cardiac muscle
which is doing the pumping
um has within it these chambers these
two atrium two ventricles um each of
which gets
um you know half
is full of blood at any given time but
half of it just came back from the lungs
and half of it just came back from the
body and
never the twin shall meet that's you
know that's that's what four chambered
heart means a three chambered heart
there is a lot of mixing uh to a two
chambered heart as well um but yeah we
and and birds and crocodilians if memory
serves with our distinctly uh separate
pulmonary and systemic systems
don't have the mixing so i don't
understand what that falsifies
well what what is it going to a spot
twice if it's not if blood isn't going
to any spot twice it's going to like
yeah you've got a vessel right right and
half of it is here and half of it is
here uh why would it why
why would it
i i don't understand because that's two
chances so i first of all i'm not
compelled that i understand the
circulation well enough to know that it
would happen first but it gets two
chances to lodge in the heart somewhere
right
oh
i guess i guess so it comes back through
some part of the heart and the eye in
the idea
oh maybe maybe i mean the thing is you
ought to be able to
a i would love to know
uh whether or not there is an asymmetry
so i thought it was about a double like
a double
dose in a particular place but no the
okay yeah somewhere in the heart
yep
all right well that's an interesting
question yep um
yeah signs of ovarian damage do exist i
think i think uh we have we know this
um
isn't it more appropriate to call it
critical race hypothesis than
theory uh except it's neither it doesn't
even rise to that level yeah i mean but
him this is the social scientists call a
lot of stuff theory that aren't that
aren't and they you know they talk as if
they're all big and important um and
making a lot of sense because they use
the word theory and when you ask them
what is it what what even is it does it
predict anything what does it even say
um
often there's no there there they just
they just stick theory on all sorts of
things so i don't think it's not a
hypothesis because there's no there's no
prediction it doesn't predict anything
it doesn't yeah well this has been uh
my point so far i think i'm the only
person who believes this but um that the
language
matters and that we ought to police
ourselves very very carefully according
to a single standard across all science
and thought where we reserve the word
theory for
the single hypothesis that has proved
out
and we don't use it anywhere else
because you know if you take even string
theory
string theory has not even risen to the
level of hypothesis
it's string notion
right it's something that could be true
yeah but we don't have a way to test it
and so the point is by calling itself
theory it seems a whole lot more
credible than it actually is and the
same thing is true here with critical
race theory it's like
critical race notion
yeah it passed no test yep
um what is the plural form of the word
virus
i think it's viruses uh isn't it yeah
although
[Music]
there's a question about what virus
actually refers to like a viral particle
would be maybe a virion
um
yeah maybe
but anyway i don't know
it's a good question
brett according to the hypothesis you
just laid out why is myocarditis
occurring more frequently in men
well
um it might in part be the catecholamine
connection could be let's put it to you
this way
there is an asymmetry between male and
female that is pretty much written into
the universe
interestingly it re-evolves with
multiple instances of male and female
that causes males to be
stronger and more fragile
and so men live shorter lives are
stronger at their peak
and this has to do with the game theory
surrounding sexual reproduction
and so
it is quite likely that one of the
advantages that men have in sport
has to do with
them being built for
extreme performance in something like
let's say warfare
right and that that extreme performance
is part of a trade-off and that it
borrows from longevity and
things like that and that basically
you know
uh
[Music]
that the heart is more capable and more
fragile in men by design
yep
which doesn't have anything to do with a
hypothesis but it doesn't need to like
you know a hypothesis to um
explain to to propose an explanation for
uh the myocarditis that that sometimes
follows mrna vaccination
is not expected to nor should it be
expected to explain all of the variation
in myocarditis
right and in fact
you know
again the subclinical manifestation is
gonna we don't actually know that this
is more common in males what we know is
that it's diagnosed more frequently and
therefore it may be that females tend to
have subclinical cases because
of differences in heart design etc
thank you for all you do heather and
brett i am at freedom camp wellington
and yesterday i walked over auckland
harbor bridge and the mandates
um i have been hearing a little bit and
i did not research it well enough to
feel like i was prepared to talk about
it today
but what is happening in new zealand uh
is extraordinary and
um you know it was it was very
uh easy and compelling and amazing to be
very focused on the trucker's convoy in
canada for for several weeks
uh and i do i do hope that what is
happening in new zealand is um a similar
a similar movement and that it uh
effectively acts as part of this giant
game of whack-a-mole uh that we need to
be playing um i i wish i knew a little
bit more i don't know how much you know
about the the protests in new zealand
but there is a lot of pushback there's a
lot of pushback to what um
what's her name yeah what trump is doing
the prime minister arden jacinda arden
yes did i make that up i don't know if
you made that up yeah did i make up the
fact that she's a uh world economic
forum
i think she may actually be from outer
space
yeah well we could send her back
yeah
um yeah maybe just put her and trudeau
in a room together and there's a lot of
people to put in that room though
um how long we've been at zach
[Music]
minutes oh okay uh let me find two more
questions
and then let's do it and uh
i'm glad that our panther here quieted
down
um
well this isn't true i'm gonna this
isn't gonna count but this is
seems
ill-spirited brett do you ever get to
point number two or letter b when you
are making a point you often say a or
one but you rarely get to point b or two
well i'm unaware of this
yeah it's not it's not true you 100 do
and in fact i know this to be true
because very often he'll say well point
one and point b yep and he often exactly
mixes them which i said he's very funny
yes he does but it does suggest that i
do get to point b
yes you do yes yes you do
um
we have a few questions here about what
um
what our thoughts are about novofax
and i just i just have not looked into
it um do you have anything
uh i saw something ominous but i am
going to delve before i
leap on that bandwagon or fail to leap
on that bandwagon
yeah
yeah okay uh let's see one more question
um
i don't know what this means do we
expect cooperative immune system
interactions within a tonsil hockey team
okay i got it i think okay um so
basically if you're if you're deeply
kissing someone
do you expect cooperative immune system
interactions
i think that there is some
tale to be told about
um
immune systems of those closely
affiliated we began to talk a little bit
about this with respect to a social
species and
one individual protecting other
individuals so just by analogy yeah
there's a
property of
schooling fish
that when an individual is
destroyed by a predator it has signals
in its cells
or in little packets
that are released into the water that
the destruction of tissue releases
fright signals into the water i know
this from um amphibian larvae
salamanders cylinder larva and tadpoles
i don't know this from fish but uh no
well early hatching but um
but
more generally uh that
uh a single destroyed tadpole in in a
pond gets everyone to run away
right yeah well and actually um
and uh accelerate development
um but but but the early hatching and
the um
workington work with um
snake is particular yep but in any case
let's put it this way we have
as a discipline under focused on lineage
and this is a reason that you hear
us use the word lineage all the time on
this podcast is because very frequently
it's the word you're looking for to
describe the thing that selection is
acting on and we have overly focused on
individuals and we have sometimes
stupidly not you and me but the
discipline is sometimes stupidly focused
on groups which aren't really an
evolutionary thing
but
lineage is the responsible way to do
this
and because lineages are a real
evolutionary thing and therefore
selection favors their preservation it
can make sense
for an individual
to protect other members of the lineage
now tonsil hockey partners
are
not exactly they are simultaneously
parts of the same bigger lineage but
they are effectively the starting point
of new lineages right
and so that partnership
um
does favor the evolution of
behaviors that
will be
uh let's say immunologically protective
so there's a question about you know is
this even what kissing is about right
could it be about some sort of
synchrony between immune systems um
and i don't know of any evidence that it
is about that but it's certainly a
plausible explanation
which takes the fun out of it but
nonetheless
um yeah
it could be a thing that that is not a
crazy idea
good
all right any last words uh wow
do you know something i don't
um you don't mean that kind of last
words no you just mean for the week yeah
just just for the week i think
uh
yeah um
yeah i just i would i would hope i would
hope that our little visit back into the
20th century will have woken us up and
we can return to the 21st century and
maybe move forward instead of regressing
and anyway i uh maybe next week we'll
have good news on that front and
we can
go back to um
you know
mocking the world for just being silly
rather than for destroying the
equilibrium that we were all depending
on yeah no i don't think we can go back
to that they're not just being silly
although many of them are just silly
yeah um
all right so consider joining us at my
patreon tomorrow for our private q a the
link will be up uh shortly and um
in the meantime
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you